bueno esto es buenas noches esto es muy
importante ya que brasil ha negado la
pandemia y las medidas de
distanciamiento social el uso de
barbijos de mucho tiempo y esto trae un
efecto cualquier medida que se
tome ahora se van a ver resultados de
cada semanas o meses entonces
evidentemente brasil está sufriendo las
consecuencias de como bien tú decías el
negacionismo por parte del liderazgo de
no utilizar las medidas de protección y
demás es mucho más fácil relajar y más
severas que no imponer las una vez
pueblo está relajado
pues justamente 13 meses después y con
300 mil 685 muertos el residente ya el
bolsón algo parece reaccionar y anuncia
la creación de un comité de emergencia y
usted que tendrá esto algunos efectos
positivos para contrarrestar la crisis
de salud es suficiente la propuesta del
presidente por sonar bueno yo creo que
cualquier propuesta que incentive el
aumento de la vacunación y de las
medidas pero esto tiene que ir a un lado
línea lógica y que hay una estrategia
mucho más mayor brasil viene de pasar el
carnaval donde sabemos que no hubo
distanciamiento donde hubo muchísimo
contagio brasil tiene una variante del
virus que se sabe que es más contagiosa
que produce enfermedad más grave y que
parecería y esto es algo que se está
recién estudiando a afectar a más
jóvenes y los más jóvenes son los que
más transmiten la enfermedad por
costumbres sociales así que todo esto es
un problema en el cual brasil debe
actuar ya mismo cambiar el curso el
timón
y tratar de implementar medidas
drásticas de distanciamiento el uso de
barbijo y vacunación a una velocidad
mayor en la que hasta ahora venía
haciendo pero grabamos un poco pero con
temor a la gente exactamente como se
relaciona la posición negacionista del
gobierno e bolsonaro con la grave crisis
que se está viendo en el país son estas
las consecuencias de la falta de una
política nacional contar con 19 y
también de una población que no ha
generado una cultura licenciamiento como
usted ya lo decía
claro yo creo que la verdad está en los
bises no no creo que haya aquí ni a un
extremo ni al otro yo también soy
partidario de fortalecer las economías
yo no estoy a favor de una cuarentena
estricta y cierre del negocio creo que
la verdad está en el meic que es uno
puede transmitir y educar a la población
aparte de patinar la que realmente se
mantengan esas medidas de
distanciamiento y vicio de máscara se va
a bajar la cantidad de contagios ahora
claro si los líderes se sacan la máscara
en público y no transmiten eso por
supuesto que el mensaje que manda hacia
abajo es totalmente distinto y opuesto